what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight spoiler video make sure you
proceed with caution with this video
because this one potentially contains
some massive spoilers for the final
season first I just have to give a
shout-out to Watchers on the wall for
bringing this exclusive update in photos
there are new spoilers for two different
locations in Westeros and I have
actually predicted some of this would
happen the first thing I want to talk
about is Winterfell and if you've seen
any of my other endgame videos then you
know I believe the Great War will take
place in Winterfell and now that more
and more photos are coming out it's
looking like we will definitely see some
sort of battle take place at this
ancient castle the Game of Thrones
production crew have already made some
significant changes to this set it
appears that they are preparing this
castle for war crenellations were
already added to the top of the walls
which are typically used for archers and
now it looks like they have even added
some siege weapons around the exterior
castle walls I forget what they are
actually called but they are basically a
type of catapult that can launch things
a pretty good distance it also looks
like they may be digging out some kind
of trench around the castle too but I'm
not exactly sure what they will be used
for just yet it would actually be pretty
crazy if they flooded it with water and
created a moat around Winterfell walls
but it's too early to tell but now that
the castles defenses are being put in
place along with siege weapons I am
confident the army of the Dead will
reach Winterfell and this is where an
all-out war will take place don't worry
though because Winterfell will not fall
but I think winter has fell here before
and I think that means a different kind
of king of winter will fall here again
and that is the night king before the
night king and his army reached
Winterfell I believe he will destroy
most of the other northern castles first
then by the time the night king reaches
Winterfell John and his team should be
ready
I expect this episode to be directed by
the great Miguel supports Nick who did
episodes like hardhome and battle of the
bastards when this great war takes place
at Winterfell it should be pretty damn
spectacular let's just hope we don't
lose all of the characters we have grown
to love but there is some other exciting
news and these spoilers are coming out
of King's Landing most of you should
I made a video about this new structure
being built on Titanic Studios law which
is the main headquarters for Game of
Thrones when they first started
constructing this building I immediately
assumed it would be in King's Landing
and according to Watchers on the walls
sources this news set well in fact to be
used for King's Landing but it's not
going to be a castle this is actually
going to be several buildings in King's
Landing most likely a city block at the
least they have also done some
controlled fire tests on this set too so
expect to see King's Landing burn just
like Daenerys all in her vision this was
foreshadowed all the way back in season
two and it's finally going to become a
reality
this episode will probably be directed
by Miguel supports NIC - it should be
pretty damn epic looking what makes this
news even more interesting is you have
to wonder how these buildings will burn
there are actually a few different
scenarios I think could take place
Cersei could always blow it up with
wildfire like she has done before
Daenerys could always burn it with her
dragons or the knight King could make it
this far south and burn King's Landing
himself I know people have always
assumed when brain saw the dragon flying
over King's Landing in his vision some
people thought that was actually the
night king flying over King's Landing
but I'm not so sure about that because I
do not see any kind of snow on the
rooftops but you never really know
regardless of who does it if the sources
are correct we will see King's Landing
burned before the series ends and it
should be fun to watch no matter who
does it but let me know what you think
about this news and put any of your
predictions down below what do you think
this means
will we see a war in Winterfell and will
we see King's Landing burn let me know
what you think also don't forget to
check out my last video about Gentry's
role in the final season I just released
that one earlier today so I'm gonna keep
this video short so thank you all for
stopping by to check it out I really
appreciate that I hope to see you all
come back for the next one bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]